let's go to berlin with german
chancellor oliver schultz is hosting
qatar zamir to me
let's have a listen to what he has to
say
three billion dollars we open regional
offices for volkswagen and other
small and medium companies in doha we
have
discussed our readiness to host the
world cup in qatar and we well we are
ready to welcome the german
fans in our country
the
german fans asked around 600
000
tickets to attend the world cup we have
bilateral rings and we had the
german in the
role in
the peace talks
sponsored by qatar in afghanistan and
chad we discussed the efforts of qatar
in afghanistan
and the evacuation of thousands to so
many destinations we agreed that there
are a lot of challenges that we need to
face with the international community in
order to pave the way for a good
standard of living for the afghan people
we are very proud and happy to evacuate
1 000 germans
in
from kabul and we thank those also who
have cooperated with germany we
discussed the international developments
to sort out the problems with iran
regarding the nuclear uh program this is
the role of qatar
that has been always played in the
region thank you very much for welcoming
and for having me here
a question to his highness your highness
following your visit to iran where you
discuss the
nuclear program what are the latest
developments in this connection
particularly after the
qatar remediation and working with the
friendly country in europe and the
states
yes we spoke uh during the visit about
the importance of
having an agreement between iran and the
european countries and the united states
in order to sort out this matter in a
peaceful way we're always optimistic
normally in this dialogue in this regard
but we are not mediators we are not
official mediators but we always want to
sort out problems in a very peaceful way
we hope our solution will be reached
this is the policy of qatar always we
believe in sorting out the disputes in a
peaceful way we in the gulf region with
iran
we must have dialogue with all other
parts in order to sort out all the
problems between countries we hope an
agreement will be reached very soon
between all parties and if they ask
qatar officially we are ready to help
and we are ready to mediate to put an
end to this dispute
question to his highness
is
a small country but is a very important
player on the geopolitical
domain
also
when it comes to gas qatar is playing an
important role how did you find such an
ambition
i did not
hey the first part of the question would
you please repeat the first part of the
okay
question
um qatar is a small country but a very
big player regarding geopolitics sports
um investments and now with the um gas
deal you will be even more powerful what
is um your goal what drives you
well first of all
speaking about sport there's a big
passion about sport in my country
whether it was parts
individuals or as teams or also as
organizing big events this is a passion
that we have it's
something that we've been doing for many
many years and we're very proud that
we're going to be hosting the world cup
in uh
in november gas we've been we've been
investing for many years in lng
[Music]
we've been investing for many years in
lng
and
we're very uh you know proud that uh
hopefully the expansion will be
there's a gas expansion that will be
ready hopefully by
2026 we understand now the energy
security is very important and gas will
is playing a very uh vital role and it's
going to be very important for the
transition period as well so this is an
investment that is very important for us
and we're looking forward as well
that especially in the gas sector that
to
explore new markets uh europe is a very
interesting market and we discussed it
with the chancellor as well this morning
how to develop this relationship
the energy crisis has been there for a
while
um it was it's got even deeper after the
war in europe but it was also before the
war uh in europe so we're very happy
that you know we're very proud that we
could also contribute on the stability
of the energy market
so ali
between germany and qatar are very good
the relations are developing and we have
a lot of domains to work and to support
and to increase
we
spoke about the
cooperation in order to overcome the
problems in the region the afghani
matter
we have talked about it and it's quite
important to work together
very closely in order to achieve and the
future will prove this we are quite
connected when it comes to
economy
it's not because of the current
situation and because of the
gaza impulse also the
inputs and exports from both countries
are increasing and this is an expression
about the good relations between our
countries we need to
continue this and we need to improve
this when it comes to the energy it's an
important matter for us
germany wants to
improve its infrastructure in order to
have
gas
pipes and
to
import gas
through ships and qatar is playing this
big role in our strategy also we
understood that this matter is not
related to germany
there are so many countries that are not
on the coastal road
and
on
the northern sea sports and they need to
be supported and qatar can't play a role
in this regard this is quite important
we talk about uh
contract
with iran
we hope that we
can have an agreement to be put on the
table of negotiations and to be accepted
by all the parties uh concerned
in order to
is there a certain quantity to
export energy when it comes to the world
cup you say that you want to welcome the
german fans in qatar what about
the german
gays
do you think they must stay in
germany german guests or do they have to
stay home
and understand
afghanistan
your technical question about the
quantities of energy we
have said that the quantities will be
doubled between 2023 to 2027 the
quantities will be doubled this is a
very
technical matter and another expert to
give you the full answer first delivery
in 2026 2027.
so these technical issues
you know um are
i said they're very technical i'm not
the best expert in answering this
question but whatever we can provide for
energy security in europe even during
this period we will make sure that we
can provide the other question um
listen everybody is welcome in doha
we do not stop anybody from coming to do
have with any different backgrounds any
different believe qatar is a very
welcoming country
we have millions of people that come and
visit our country
and the world cup is a great opportunity
for people from different parts of the
world to come and experience
our culture
we will not stop anybody from coming
visiting and enjoying the football
but i want also everybody to come
and understand and enjoy also the
culture to see different cultures as
well
we all live in one
planet
but each of us have different cultures
we welcome everybody but also we expect
and we want people to respect our
culture
so this is my answer going to be for you
thank you
the
germans will go to qatar to celebrate
with the teams
and when it comes to human rights we we
discuss these
matters we have done this before and
today when it comes to
the
labor's rights
a lot of changes has been
entered
in
this connection a lot of
legal relations have been
inserted in order to
boost the relations between the owners
of the businesses and the labors and i
know there is always a good chance
to improve there's always a good room to
improve and we cannot forget the very
great uh
efforts
that have taken me to politics
first of all my the
attitude to defend the rights of the
laborers we have a lot of consultations
and discussions and this is part of our
visit today
thank you thank you very much
if you're just joining us we've been
listening to the german chancellor olaf
schultz uh who was hosting qatar's amir
shaikh to mean bin hamad al-thani in
berlin just giving a press conference
there to the media
germany has been has of course been
looking to qatar for alternatives to
russian energy and the german chancellor
is saying that qatar will play a central
role in our strategy of diversifying
away from russian gas we're just looking
at the latest pictures there of that
press conference let's go to dominic
kane in berlin you've been listening
into that press conference
what stood out for you
what stood out there is there's no
question that both sides are very keen
to carry on discussing with each other
this idea of qatari liquid natural gas
being part of the solution to germany's
problems but remembering that germany
wants to get itself off to wean itself
off
russian fossil fuels as quickly as
possible and so it's pretty clear from
the german government that's what they
want to do they see this a potential
deal with qatar as helping them to do
that but there are some serious sticking
points with a potential deal with qatar
three points that stand out and we
didn't hear those points being addressed
in what we just heard from both sides
there expressions of interest of intent
of solidarity friendship but no really
clear detail about what exactly a deal
between these two countries for lng
delivery would entail
and uh
it wasn't just energy that they were
talking about they talked about a number
of other things including uh
human rights
what did you make of the comments on
that
one of the things that that viewers need
to have in mind when they consider
meetings between the emir of qatar and
the german chancellor
is the geopolitical element so obviously
we heard about gas the human rights
angle here in germany there is a loud
vociferous body which looks at the state
of qatar and has concerns about human
rights particularly as we heard in some
of the questions quite pointed questions
to both speakers there about the
situation for particular minorities in
society were they to travel to qatar so
we heard from the emir of qatar quite
clearly that all are welcome in qatar
but he hoped that that different
cultures would come together but there
would be respect for qatari culture from
the german perspective clearly
human rights is a very central plank of
policy as it were particularly for this
chancellor a social democrat chancellor
so it is interesting that it may not
necessarily be the most clear meeting of
minds between these two men on that
particular angle but it did stand out as
being an interesting element which the
journalists there were quite clear to us
pointed questions about
okay thank you for that dominic kane
there for us in berlin